"For as long as you can remember,"
"Legends have been told about the derelict mansion upon the hill that casts a blanket of darkness over the town."
"The history of the house itself is virtually unknown,"
"And even the town's oldest residents cannot remember the mansion's origins."
"Being an avid history enthusiast, you embark up to the mountain to visit the manor."
"Hoping to shed some light on the backstory of this crumbling fortress of darkness."
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Spooky's Jump Scare Mansion.
Formerly Spooky's House of Jump Scares, but now Spooky's Jump Scare Mansion HD Renovation.
The entire game has been rebuilt, in a brand new engine, in Full HD quality. Ooh. Huhuhu.
So, I'm going to be going into the mansion once again, because number one-- whoa.
You oh, so nice. Oh, it looks so good. Oh?
Woah! ... hi
Hellooo,
How are you doing?
Uh huh,
Okay
I've done it before
Probably not...
Okay, alright, thanks Spooky. You have a good day.
Okay, so I'm gonna go and I'm gonna go in these rooms
And I'm gonna see all what for but as you can obviously tell it's different because number one
It looks a little better, but obviously number two there's a lot more diversity to what can go on it here even though
it's probably gonna be a lot of this room wandering, so let's see what's in store in the jump-scare mansion, so I
*suspenseful swell*
Hello Bread, how are you doing? You're not very scary that's for damn sure.
Nice bed.
Ooh,
bones
I like the sounds? they upped up the sounds. the creep factor is definitely there. Oh, hi
Hello, hi bones. How are you doing? Whoa? Hi bed. Oh, hello beds. Alright, see ya
Fuck you
You ain't gonna scare me with those pathetic skills, you gotta be scaring up a much spookier sentence. For what it's worth
I'm gonna go through the first like hundred or so and just see
Just see if there's some spooktacular things, (Glorp interuption)
Waiting for me in the darkness. What are you goop? what are you fog?
I don't know what you are, but I don't like it. Oh rumble increases
heyyyy,
fuuudge is a candy...
and i like it
Is that a baby crib?
In- in a (dramatic noise) cave???
oof
Is that the timeout chair looking at a wall? I dont like it nonono. Why is there another door over there? That's the question right?
Why are there so many multiple?
That's a thing that happened whoa hey, buddy whoo that gives me the creeps
It's Redman beds whoa here we go. Hey whoa?
That's so nice hang in there I will. GL lab, thats noice
(SNIIIFFF)
Looks like there's gonna be oh no another timeout chair. I don't know which way is the right way to goes
Oh good. I picked correctly
Come on now
Come on
Come on. You, ghosts. Why is there another timeout chair up there? Why is there so many people needing to be put into timeout?
I don't like that. I know what that is ah
Spouting splashing soaking innards ingest evoking nailing never stops a joke why okay?
That's what that summoned. I shouldn't have read that out loud
That's not what I should have done. Oh that is bad
Jump over it oh, I can't jump, you know that'll teach me for reading random bits of paper strewn about everywhere
Oh, you never know when you're gonna summon a demon
Okay seems like we got away from it. That's good
You don't know where I'm gonna come fool you if you do that. Here's a hint
It's gonna be up your butt straight up your behold. Yeah, where am I going? Oh bony? How you doing buddy? Oh you look good?
You've earned yourself a new is olive oil
Ice-cream or what are you cupcake ice cream or a cupcake answer my goddamn?
Questions figured shit out man leave it to me whoa, okay, but I was in a box
Why did I hear breathing was it you? Oh? That's why oh hey? This is going friend
like
I thought I was done with you. Oh this we're
You doing okay, you got to follow the rails don't
100 let's do a hundred okay, that was pretty good keep a little pep in your step go down. Oh
Somebody will oil that door Oh Goldie I
Could be flying get away tentacle ban and one of the things actually gonna get spooky opinion well, I spoke me scare me
honey, please somebody please wait
Whoa
Well found the sewer well. It's awfully goopy in here. It's like a lot of this place is suspiciously goopy
You know I expect a normal level of goo pitch in every place that I go to so when it's above level
average doo doo I
Heard that I heard that I heard that sorry about don't mean to complain about the goog levels. Goop levels are perfectly adequate
Oh, well that fog in my face is probably a bad sign
And remember what that is though? Well that's locked. Okay? Well that's no good. Hehe
I think something's gonna leave me when I die. Oh well
This is- ah! Okay
OOOoohh
OOoh we're in a loop. We're in a loop-de-loop. Maybe if I go backwards. Yep. Oh, no wait no oh god. No
no, oh
What's nice? We're we're we're we're all
Oh
Hey, buddy, Oh Baby how you doing
Good, okay, well this is
o1 Zeus copied some tech 5 has grown more Restless
I told the spook we need more funds for sedatives
And she just laughed and flew into the ceiling without more chemicals to keep these things
Docile, and not sure how much longer we can safely keep them generic lab assist
What kind of person would work in a lab in a mansion? How did they even get here?
We stand under that
Yup, that's a hole all right
I believe subject 5 is loose the glass is shattered and I can faintly hear clicking coming from the ceiling
I don't know. What will happen now if it's out in alive. It'd probably be my last report the clicking is getting louder. Oh
- Oh
Lilly I don't like that. I don't like that. I don't know what was going on, but I don't like it
Well, Shah I'm dead. I'm dead. I'm dead. I'm dead. I'm dad dad. I'm dad
That's the wrong way to go, that's wrong hi I fucked it now
Okay, well oh
Okay, maybe I just keep running then I guess I'm not done
Here we go
The clicking has stopped in the giant holes in the ceiling or not there anymore. This is my last note. I'm gonna die
I've never found my escape
But really that's not true this place was like my escape when I escaped from everything else in the end my deaths got a romantic
Okay, whatever you're dead not cup of joe who ballroom. There are nice
But apparently we're not what whoa whoa that's not good pony run
Hey
Bonnie you made it Oh Bonnie. Oh Bonnie you're such a good corner keep that blood pumping you got it buddy there
Oh, Oh big and red you like big red lump in this before oh
You goofy that's a new sound those are new sounds. I love new sounds anything by me, okay
Gosh shit, I did bad. Oh God which way to go
Locked oh, they're locked it wouldn't have mattered none. Anyway. I can't read it miss sir. He never came to class today
I hope she made it home. Okay? Oh?
Something tells me it's matsuri made it to class just fine. Oh
Could it really be true
I thought the fairy tales about the ghost that eats children who sneak in after class was just keep us from disobeying
But Matsuri is still missing
huh the ghost that eats children
For a project well that just means don't go to class if you're late. Just don't go you won't get eat
You won't be at the rumbling in my tumbly it seems to
The music seems very counter Wampus to what's actually going on here
Ah back to the choirs of the Damned my ideal environment for thinking
*car sounds?*
whats all the jails for-   BONY NOOOOOOOOOO
o do woah woah brain brain brain
Hey brainy! how ya doin :)
Brainy you have a good one thinking and such whatever brains do masturbate probably
hello? hello hello!
Five nights at freddys
FUAHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH pumpkin
Whoa okay Wow fog alright well then well back to me. Oh it's all the time out chairs and bony
well thank you for being here at the end oh that was lovely alright, so anyway that is
Spooky's House of jump-scares HD renovation
There's probably a lot of new stuff in here but most of this I believe I've seen over the years that I played this game
Still really cool to see that
There's a full HD remake
And I know it's pretty nice feels a lot better to run through it than it did before so check it out for yourself
It's on Steam and thanks again for watching
Let me know what you think down the comments below and as always I will see you in the next video. Bye Bye!